in the set of integers let p be the
proposition and then you've got this
sort of structure in here right um
you've got an if then statement so
that's pretty sort of
normal and you've got this first part
which what we like to call the
antecedent uh you know here's the
condition if k 1 is divisible by 3 and
then you've got this other part over
here which we call the consequent
proposition
you know what's the result if you meet
that first condition right
so we want to prove that this is true
how do we go about doing this um it's
kind of fairly straightforward to say
well let's just start with the
antecedent proposition and then see if
we can reason from that using arithmetic
and algebra to get to our consequent
proposition if can we start with a and
then get to b if we can call this i
suppose you know a implies
b
uh can we start with a and then arrive
at b
through some fairly simple working and i
think we can
so where am i going to begin just like a
normal divisibility thing is to say that
you know if k plus 1 division by 3 i can
state that algebraically i can say let k
plus 1
be equal to some multiple of 3 to be
divisible by 3 and to be a multiple of 3
are
synonymous in this context right so i'm
going to say let's call that 3n
where
both k and n are integers they do say
right at the beginning in the set of
integers so that's kind of just applied
to everything but i think it's important
to actually say it in our proof
because i'm going to have to appeal to
this fact later on uh to do some of my
reasoning okay
so i've made that statement and this is
the a part right k plus 1 divides by 3
and i have to somehow get to the b
part which has a k cubed plus one so in
order to get from this k statement i
think i'm going to need to cube
something right so therefore i'm just
going to cube both sides and that will
give me this k plus 1 or cubed
equals 3m
all
cubed so you're going to need to be
careful with expanding this binomial
expression over here on the left but
hopefully i mean you guys have got a
head start on me hopefully you're
getting something like this k cubed plus
3 k squared plus 3 k plus 1
didn't quite give myself enough space
there and on the right hand side i'm
going to get 27 n cubed so again i've
just done some fairly simple
manipulation of
those two expressions
now from here like i've just expanded
great but what was the point of that
okay and the answer is i want to try and
find this this expression here k cubed
plus 1 which is part of the b
half of the statement um i want to show
that that thing is divisible by three so
it also should be three times some stuff
right and maybe you're starting to see
well i can i can poke out this k cubed
plus one just without much effort it's
already there on the left hand side and
i just need to kind of sift out get rid
of all of the other stuff right so
that's exactly what i'm going to do if i
subtract
everything else from both sides except
for the k cubed and the plus one then
i'm good to go right so you got 27 n
cubed over here i'll take away the 3k
squared and i'll also take away the 3k
so at this point i'm like almost there
right um you've got the 27 you've got
the three you've got the three this is
easy to factorize out so i'm gonna do
that
everything in here
of course i need to actually make this
statement
that everything in here has to be a
whole number because if you just because
you've got like three times something
that doesn't mean that you've got a
multiple of three i could say you know
is five divisible by three because
that's equal to three times five thirds
but five thirds is not an integer right
so that component the other factor needs
to be an integer so i'm actually going
to sort of draw out based on my um
earlier reasoning up here the fact that
is true i can say but
k and n if they're integers
k and n if they are integers what that
implies is that no matter how many times
you add or subtract or multiply these um
integers by whole numbers you'll still
stay in whole number land right you'll
still stay an integer so this
this statement here that k n are
integers implies that 9 n cubed minus k
squared minus k
is also
an integer that whole expression okay so
therefore i can say therefore
k cubed plus one
that's going to be three times some
other integer i'm just going to call it
m
like so
and at this point like logic wise i'm
finished i should just kind of tie this
up in a neat bow in other words k cubed
plus one
is divisible by three
okay
so i'll put a full stop on that and i
feel happy about part one so i would
love it if you can i'm gonna keep on
going but i will come back to the chat
in a second um i if you have a very
different a dramatically different
solution to this then um please let me
know um i do see a question there about
uh it's come through directly so if you
look in the chat thinking you're like
where'd this question come from um it's
about are we allowed to use that
vertical line which you often see is
like the brackets for absolute value um
it's actually called the pipe symbol
anyway are we allowed to use that that
symbol for divisibility
if a is divisible by b can we use this
kind of notation uh the short answer is
yes you can but at your own risk um this
form of notation here you'll see in a
lot of textbooks mainly because i think
the textbook authors are trying to like
save space and they're typing it many
dozens of times so they're like sick of
writing it over and over again
um so it is a form of notation that is
used i
don't tend to use it i mean you can see
i didn't use it at all in my working
main reason being
you wouldn't believe the number of times
someone does that sort of long symbol
but then they misread their own writing
and they're like i don't know what is
that b l a b one a i don't know um it's
it's sort of
it sort of straddles that um that world
of notation that's used just
infrequently enough that it's not
obvious to everyone and the number of
times people even in the at4 misread
their own working and then just carried
on their working and carried forward an
error it's a bit embarrassing um i think
when we have sort of um absolute value
notation you've generally got context in
the algebra that makes it clear what
you're doing right but that's kind of
why i steer away from this notation
for what it's worth this exact symbol
comes up in another form which i also do
not tend to use and that's a definite
integrals right so i know several of you
like this notation because i see you use
it all the time
sometimes people will say oh if i'm
integrating
from 1 to 3 2x dx right
the standard form of notation that we
use for a definite integral is to use
these big square brackets right we say
integrate that from 1 to 3. i know a lot
of you even in the most recent
assessment task
have kind of ditched that notation and
use this one right it's the same kind of
you know
mathematicians are so lazy with like
let's use like what's the simplest
symbol we can have it's just a line it's
just a longer one right um and and this
i i will agree like if i see this i do
know what it means because i've seen
lots of notation
i still don't like it i never use it
especially because when you sort of say
in a recurrence relation or even when
you're doing just integration by parts
once and you've got a definite integral
appearing and then there's like some
other you know there's like a minus
integral of v to u off on the end here
um i just think it just it it opens up
so much ambiguity and you're kind of
like oh where is the rest of like where
does this definite integral end um i'm
not a i'm not a fan okay
so uh so that's that's what i would say
in terms of using that notation uh can
you use it yes but i i don't use it and
that's for the reasons that i just
stated
mrs lee is you have a question
or a point to
not a raise
i'm just intrigued by perham's question
and thought you might like a second to
read it oh of course okay so i thought
i'd stick my nose in give you that
second to read it yeah thank you okay so
um questions can we just factorize k
cubed plus one into um and you've got
there a sum of cubes result okay um so
if i go ahead and take this result over
here k cubed plus one by the way thank
you pahan for pointing that out we can
use a sum of cubes results so it is uh
same
opposite
always positive before this was a result
that you got given to you
this is something we had to memorize so
can you use this okay so if k cubed if k
plus 1 is a multiple of 3 because that's
what that's our
antecedent
condition um then this is k q plus 1 so
that's also going to be divisible by 3
because it has the k plus 1 in it yeah
totally fine with me
i do like that as a result because you
can avoid all of this sort of algebra
that i've just done through here so
thumbs up for me
i didn't do it because i didn't think of
it so thank you i did ask for other
people to give me
other methods but yeah i have no issue
with it the logic seems fine to me